let's do a few examples of writing
expressions to help us solve word
problems so they tell a Suzy ran a race
she ran five miles an hour and the race
took her T hours to complete how long
was the race write your answer as an
expression all right if we're trying to
figure out the number of miles you'd
want to take her speed which is in miles
per hour so five miles per hour times
the number of hours so the number of
hours is T so you could literally just
write that as five T 5 T literally means
5 times T now another way you could have
done it is you could have use this
little dot symbol here this is not a
decimal it's it's higher than a decimal
and it means multiplication five times T
either that either of these five dot T
or five T means 5 times T it makes sense
you take your speed times your time and
you'll figure out how far you actually
went check my answer here let's do a few
more of these the running aces card team
won five hundred forty eight dollars
playing poker in tournaments last year
the winnings were split evenly among the
P place how much how much of money did
each how much I guess you say how much
money not how much of money is a
grammatical error how much money did
each player receive write your answer as
an expression so they had five hundred
and forty eight dollars and hit the
split it evenly among the P place so
they're going to split it so I'm just
going to backs last year or I literally
could have I could have just clicked on
this as well five hundred forty eight
divided by P I'm going to divide the
amount of money we got amongst the
number of players so that's how much
money each player actually receives
let's check the answer and got it right
let's do a few more of these Phil
received a prize of X dollars from a
poker tournament the tournament cost him
a hundred dollars to enter what were
Phil's net winnings from the tournament
write your answer as an expression or
his net winnings okay he gets X dollars
but it's not like he just walks away
with X I mean he does get the X dollars
but he had to pay something to enter the
tournament he had to pay a hundred
dollars to enter the tournament so for
example if
X was 105 dollars he wins 105 dollars
but if he had to spend a hundred dollars
to enter the tournament that his net
would be a hundred five minus 100 or
five dollars so this is giving us the
net we're getting how much he got but
we're subtracting how much he actually
had to spend let's do one more of these
Hilary made 48 chocolate chip cookies
and why sugar cookies how many total
cookies did Hilary make well 48
chocolate chip cookies and then to add
that the number of sugar cookies she
made and there you have it that's the
total number of cookies she made it she
made two sugar cookies this would why
would be two and she would have made a
total of 50 cookies if she made a
hundred sugar cookies then this would be
a hundred plus 48 which would be 148
total cookies so hopefully that gives
you a little bit of practice and I
encourage you to do this exercise so you
get a lot more practice